[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIO FINOCCHIARO: Don't let
the title of the presentations
fool you.
Although we are going to be
focusing on an automotive use
case, which we think is
a great use case for IoT,
everything that we
talk about is going
to be applicable to lots of
IoT, industrial IoT use cases.
So there's definitely
something here for everybody.
And the three
things that I think
we hope that people walk
away from this session
are, number one is that
you really walk away
with a sense of what it takes to
succeed in IoT from a business
perspective, right?
Number one.
Number two is a real world
example with Mitsubishi talking
about their Mitsubishi
Connect program,
and the real value
that they're creating
for themselves as a company,
and their customers.
And then we're super happy
to announce our partnership,
Google Cloud's
partnership with Aeris,
where you're going to hear about
their full stack IoT platform
and how that helps
customers navigate
a lot of the complexity in
IoT, rapidly innovate, and just
deliver that value really
quickly to customers.
So that's basically what
we have in store for you
over the next 50 minutes.
Sound good?
All right.
Good interactive crowd.
We get a little--
OK.
So if you're here,
you're here for IoT.
And the good news
is IoT is growing.
So just a quick stat that
I pulled from a company
called IoT Analytics that
does competitive research
for IoT, industrial
IoT, and Industry 4.0.
It's showing that
for enterprises
that they surveyed, whereas
12% of enterprises back in 2018
had said they had
implemented IoT projects,
that that number is
increasing to 50% by 2021.
So couple things I think
take away from this stat
is number one,
there's growth, right?
And it's still a little
bit early in IoT,
but there's a lot
of growth happened.
There's a lot of
innovation happening.
This is a very good time
to be thinking about IoT.
And specifically, one of things
that we see really clearly
is this transition
where a lot of companies
are moving from a proof
of concept phase and pilot
phase to real deployment of
IoT solutions and production.
And over the next
three years, you're
going to see this
clearly increase.
It's just a stat that
kind of indicates that.
But this growth does
beg the question.
And the question I think
it begs is, so how do you
be successful in this growth?
How do you take advantage of it?
So I put together
this framework having
had the benefit of being in
IoT for the past six years,
developing an IoT platform
and being here with Google
and many of our
customers, outlining
what we call the seven steps
to business success in IoT.
And it's basically
a framework, or way
to think about how to navigate
the daunting, sometimes,
set of business considerations,
technical considerations,
and even sometimes
cultural change
that has to happen within a
company or a customer base
in order to really
be successful in IoT.
So I'm going to step
through this quickly.
And there's a lot
more behind it,
but let's just kind of start
at the first part, the business
case.
So the first thing
about the business case
is you have to have one.
I think the biggest indicator,
one of the biggest indicators
of success that we've seen
in working with companies who
have embarked on
this IoT journey
is that the companies
have answered
three fundamental questions
really, really well.
Number one is who
is my customer?
Number two is what
is the new value
that we want to deliver to
them with a connected service?
And number three is how does
that new customer value then
fold back into my business
and add value to my business?
And ideally, some way to really
measure that and show clear
ROI.
Companies that
have done that work
are just really set very well to
make many of the other business
decisions and technical
decisions a lot
more effectively.
If not, we jokingly-- my team
would refer to something called
the IoT cul-de-sac, which
is not a dead end road,
but it's kind of like you get
down the road for a while,
and you realize you haven't
really thought through your end
game, and you have to turn
around and go back and start
from the beginning.
So number one.
Number two is the
connected product itself.
So this is for OEMs, who are
often the ones implementing
IoT solutions, this is the
one that can sound easy
because that's what you do.
You make a physical product.
But when a physical product
becomes part of a 24
by 7 connected
service, there can
be all sorts of
new considerations,
as you can imagine.
The question is,
with a connected car,
is it a car with
a computer in it,
or is it a smartphone
on wheels, right?
What really is it?
And this has impact
on everything
from mechanical design,
all the buttons and knobs
that you would normally
have, still needed
if you're now going to control
those virtually or via an app,
right?
That affects the electrical
design, electronics design,
connectivity design.
Are you going to use wired
networking, Bluetooth, Wi-Fi,
ZigBee cellular?
Which type of cellular?
Where in which regions?
Low power wide area networking,
all these considerations
that come just into the physical
product that are different
then if it's not a part
of a connected solution.
The Cloud platform, as you're
picking a cloud partner,
does that partner bring the
global scale security, tools,
capabilities that
you need to have
to be the platform upon which a
lot of this solution is built?
And the user
application, so that's
kind of an interesting
one, because if you
look at two and four,
user applications
and the connected product,
these are two areas
where you're building the part
that will interact directly
with the customer.
And one is physical
and one is digital.
And you have this
kind of interplay
between the physical
and digital world,
and then IoT, as you
know, a lot of the value
starts to shift from the
traditional physical product
into the digital world.
But this brings up some
opportunities, of course,
but also some
challenges, and maybe
even some culture changes.
I think, Bryan, you'll talk
a little bit about this.
Because you develop
software a lot differently
than you develop hardware,
but they have to be
in sync with each other, right?
So sometimes there's
even a cultural change
in a company that has
to take place here.
Then the next step,
hopefully when
you're embarking on an IoT--
on the IoT journey,
you're not just
building a connected product.
But you are really running
a connected business
for the benefit
of your customers.
And what this often
means is how do you
integrate data from these
services into business systems
that you use to run
your business every day?
If that's a CRM system, if
it's a marketing automation
platform, if it's an ERP system,
if it's a ticketing system,
[INAUDIBLE],, that's
something to really
think about, the capabilities
of those platforms
and the limitations also and
how that ties into the equation.
Next, who's heard IoT's
all about the data, right?
Show of hands.
The hands are a little weak.
Everyone's heard that.
Or data is the new oil.
We've got to change this to
be a little more renewable.
I think we should
start saying in IoT,
data is the new sunshine.
Is it too soft?
Data is the new sunshine?
I think-- I think we could--
let's tag it right now.
That's the first
time it was said.
But the point is that IoT
is more than just connecting
devices and connecting people.
There is a lot that can be done
and needs to be thought out
with the data.
What types of new
insights can you
derive that you could
never derive before?
What understanding
of a customer can you
have that you were never
able to have before?
And this blending of IoT
with smart analytics,
artificial intelligence,
and machine learning
is absolutely a trend
that we're seeing,
and we the industry is
evolving towards as well.
Finally-- and this is
probably the most overlooked--
when a company goes after
the opportunity of the IoT,
the companies that also do a
really good job of thinking
about the obligations that
they now are taking on
by becoming a 24 by 7 service
provider is really important.
Because in balancing the
opportunity and obligation,
when you're a 24 by
7 service provider,
you have a different
support expectation
from your customers.
They expect that 24 by 7.
And if you bake that into the
business case and the solution,
you have the whole
thing together.
So it starts and ends
with the customer.
Starts and ends
So two more quick slides, and
then I'm going to pass it on.
If you're with-- if you spend
much time with me or my team,
you're going to hear
that you cannot--
no company can do IoT alone.
And what we kind of jokingly
say, but seriously say too
is there's always three legs
to the stool to implementing
an IoT solution.
There's a platform, an
enterprise class platform,
like Google Cloud
Platform is the foundation
upon which a lot is
built. Then there's
an ecosystem of partners,
a best in class partners
that really provide the
hardware-software connectivity,
and those pieces that
really either fill in gaps,
or accelerate innovation
from customers.
Now, Aeris is a great
example of a partner
that provides us full stack
IoT solution with Google Cloud.
You'll hear a lot
more about that.
And then you always
need pro services.
So platform, partners,
and pro services.
Because no solution is
complete, you always
need experts, either domain
experts or technology experts,
to help bring it all together.
So we as Google Cloud
with respect to IoT,
we never engage with customers
without bringing in partners.
We're always
bringing in partners.
And there's always--
the three legs
of the stool are always there
to stand up the solution.
And lastly, I'll spend the
least amount of time on this.
But if you look at from the
platform perspective, what
Google Cloud brings is a
set of managed services that
allow companies to connect
millions of devices and just
that data, process,
clean, store that data,
and then develop those
insights and business
outcomes that you want.
And this is a platform
that with the other two
legs of the stool, brings
the whole solution together
for customers.
So with that, I'd
love to hand it off
to Bryan, who's
going to tell you
a little bit about Mitsubishi.
BRYAN ARNETT: Great.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Bryan Arnett.
I am a-- not an IoT guy.
MARIO FINOCCHIARO: [INAUDIBLE]
BRYAN ARNETT: Oh,
I need this thing.
As you can see.
I am actually-- I'm
a product planner.
I've been a product planner
for the OEM industry
for over 25 years.
I've worked with--
I currently work with
Mitsubishi Motors,
and was recently tasked
about two years ago
to investigate as part of the
product planning operation
at Mitsubishi Motors to get
into this telematics game.
We saw a lot of--
as you guys know, there's
the General Motors,
and a lot of the OEMs
out there are all
talking about connected
cars and what connected cars
means to the OEM industry.
And we needed to
figure this out.
We need to get
part of this game.
So we started to investigate
the telematics industry.
And we started talking with
many different suppliers,
including Aeris.
What we quickly learned is
that the biggest lesson of all
is we come from two
completely different worlds.
In the automotive industry,
we have been building cars
for 100 years using waterfall
approach to engineering.
Our engineers are basically
ingrained in their methodology
and go through a series
of waterfall check-ins.
And so suddenly, when
we start bringing
in IoT into the onboard
environment, into the vehicle,
we start to realize that
we need to blend these two
worlds together.
We need to have some
type of a hybrid approach
between waterfall development
and agile development.
And so what we're finding is
that there's two cultures.
And we as an automotive
manufacturer,
we need to learn how
to be more agile.
And you'll hear that from
probably a lot of OEMs
out there from the
automotive side.
You'll read how
automotive manufacturers
need to think faster and need to
move faster to be competitive.
And so by partnering with Aeris
and working on the IoT space,
we actually learned how
to improve our culture
from an engineering
perspective to implement more
an agile approach
to our development,
and start rethinking basically
how we develop vehicles
from a more agile point of
view, not just a waterfall
point of view.
So like any good
connected car program,
we need to start with a vision.
So what is it that we want?
So essentially, we
encapsulated our vision
as the car will be integrated
into the IoT network
by advanced connected car
technology of Mitsubishi
Motors.
In the future, our
connection to each other
and the world around
us will only grow.
We will be part of the
Internet of Things,
connecting you more
directly to your world.
Mitsubishi connect will provide
innovative connected services
by applying the
information network
to provide a more personalized
and rich driving experience.
And what is really
important here
is the statement
where it says we
will be part of the
Internet of Things,
connecting you more
directly to your world.
So a lot of times
manufacturers think of things
as a hardware perspective.
We connect a cell
phone to a car,
and we do a remote engine
start, and we're done.
What we need to
start thinking about
is connecting the customer to
the car, not just the devices.
And so this is also something
that automotive OEMs
are starting to think about.
How do we connect our
customers into our world,
not just bring our device--
bring their devices
into our car.
So that's something that is
very important as we also
look at what is our
strategy going forward.
The US traditionally has
been the largest market
for telematics services
in the United States.
Almost all OEM major
brands now have
some sort of aggressive fitment
penetration in connected cars.
And as you know,
traditionally, most
of the automotive profitability,
over a majority of it,
is traditionally gained by
fixed operation expenses, sale
of oil, sale of parts,
maintenance, services,
things like that.
With the growth of
electric vehicles
rapidly being realized
in the marketplace,
some of these traditional
fixed operational services
and some of these
traditional revenues
are going to disappear.
So we need to start
thinking about new business
models and new ways to
generate new future service
revenues for things in
the automotive sector
and becoming more
connected to our customers
and delivering more on-demand
related services through IoT.
You can see from the
chart here, which
is provided by SPD
Automotive, by 2025,
over 90% of all vehicles
shipped to the United States
will have an embedded
connected, and also
a smartphone-tethered
device in the vehicle.
So within a very
short period of time,
within the next
five years or so,
virtually every vehicle
shipped in the United States
will have some sort
of connected device.
So you're looking at a SAAR of
about 17 million new cars sold
every year.
So by 2025, you're going to
see a rapid expansion of IoT
and services being offered
in the automotive space.
So we have only five
years to really learn
how to get this right.
So from Mitsubishi's
perspective,
we looked at it from kind
of a three-stage approach.
I guess this is kind
of like your stool.
First, we looked at it
from phase one perspective.
So we introduced something
called a Smartphone Link
Display Audio.
Most people know
this as Android Auto.
We introduced the Android Auto
capability into our vehicles,
and we have a tethered
smartphone system
in our vehicle where we can do
custom OEM applications that
are approved by Google and can
be downloaded from the Google
App Store and put on your
cell phone, and so forth.
Then beginning in
2018, just last year,
we introduced Mitsubishi
Connect, which is basically
a TCU, or a Telematics
Control Unit,
or an embedded device that is
installed into the vehicle.
And then next, for
our phase three,
we get into more
of the analytics.
And this is where we are
going to start learning more
about our customers, how
to service our customers,
and how to grow our
business, and then
the service retention of our
customers through the analytics
that we're going to gain
through both the data that
comes from the TCU,
and the data that
comes from the tethered device.
So today, Mitsubishi Connect
system is in the market.
It launched about a year ago.
We offer a two-year we call
Safeguard and Remote Service
bundle with the purchase
of any Mitsubishi vehicle
that is equipped with this.
So Safeguard Services
include things
like automatic collision
notification, SOS emergency
assistance, roadside assistance,
stolen vehicle tracking.
Remote services include things
like remote climate control,
remote door lock, car
finder, parental settings,
things like that, all of
which offer connectivity
through your smartphone.
And you can see the application
there in the center.
We also offer Google
Home capability, where
you can use Google,
talk to your car
through the Google Home
device to remote start.
And so now we're
starting to establish
a relationship between
the customer and the car
more directly when
you're not in the car.
And so that's very important.
Typically, OEMs only were
able to make a relationship
or establish some kind of
connection with the customer
when they were driving and
when they were in the car.
Now we're able to
start establishing
some type of a
relationship and starting
to be able to provide
some branding exercise
to those customers when
they're away from the car.
And so when they have
their smartphone,
or they're at home in the
morning getting ready to go,
just simply ask Google
to start their car,
precondition the
climate control.
So some of the key
business challenges
that we faced that
we were looking at,
Mitsubishi generally is
a much smaller company
than the Toyotas or the
Volkswagens of the world.
So economies of scale were very
important and necessary for us
to make a valid business case.
We talked a little earlier
about having the business case.
So of course, we
had a business case.
And we knew right away that
in order to make this work,
we needed to do it
on a global scale.
We did not necessarily have
the volumes only in the United
States, or we didn't
have the volumes
only in the European market.
So we needed to look at this
from a big global perspective.
And so we started looking
at what kind of partnerships
we could have in
that perspective.
And quite frankly,
there weren't many,
with the exception
of maybe Aeris.
So we needed somebody to deliver
automotive grade IoT services
on a global scale.
We needed a vendor to help us
to provide technical leadership
and manage the complexities
that we were quickly
realizing, as an
automotive manufacturer,
we weren't experts in IoT.
We were car guys.
We needed somebody who
could help us become experts
and guide us in the IoT place.
And lastly, we
needed somebody that
could be flexible and adapt
to the automotive processes
and change requests
that we constantly make.
We're a waterfall
development company.
We're learning as we go.
We needed somebody that was
flexible and easy to work with,
and understood that we're
learning along with them.
So one of the partners here
that will speak next is Aeris.
They have delivered on
a lot of this for us
and have been able to be
really instrumental in helping
us manage the complexity,
and helping me
and our team at Mitsubishi
worldwide learn the IoT space.
The next thing we
needed was Mitsubishi
needed an end-to-end
modular solution that
could adapt globally and grow
at the speed of the feature
innovation.
So we needed to look at the
stack of technology that
was available.
And here's basically a
picture of Aeris full stack
of services.
So the edge client, the
connectivity manager,
the IoT transition
services, the core services,
all the TSP services, including
the call center operations.
You can see the
complexity gets quite
overwhelming from an
automotive manufacturer.
So we needed somebody
to handle all of this,
and then we also
needed somebody who
would be able to be flexible
with this stack in case
something were to
change in the future,
or be able to adjust this stack.
So this is one of
the key requirements
we had of a supplier.
And then lastly, as I mentioned,
we needed the ability to work
with our MNO partner-- we
currently work with AT&T--
the mobile network
operators to provide
seamless 4G LTE connectivity,
SIM provisioning,
turning on the SIM chip,
turning off the SIM chip,
managing the
subscriber statuses.
All of that needed to be done.
The call center
authentication tool
needed to be developed
from a global perspective,
not just in the United
States, but also in Europe
and around the world.
And then we also needed--
we needed a kind
of connectivity,
a connected vehicle ecosystem
that provides significant--
that provides a significant
threat for hackers.
Basically, the industry needs
to have a secure vehicle, right?
As we start getting
into the IoT space,
and we start bringing
the outside world
kind of into our vehicle, one of
the biggest concerns of an OEM
is the security of the vehicle.
Obviously, we are a very
heavily regulated industry.
I think there is a
government agency for just
about everything related to
the connected car with NTSA,
or the Homeland Security, or
Department of Transportation,
or whatever.
We are constantly having
to report to the government
authorities.
And so here comes IoT,
and we're, oh, god,
what government authority do
we have to report to now when
it comes to this?
So security is one of
the things we definitely
wanted to make sure we
had a good handle on.
So we need to secure the vehicle
while protecting the driver.
We needed the ability to
update the hardware, our apps,
and our services without
inconveniencing our customers.
And we needed to be able
to differentiate services
based upon the identity
of the primary owner,
or the secondary
owner, or whether it
was a fleet customer, or
was it a retail customer.
We have many different
types of customers when it
comes to purchasing vehicles.
And so it's very important
when connecting a car
to not just connect the car,
but to connect the customer.
And so in order to
connect a customer,
we have to know who
that customer is.
We have to be able to
control and manage that.
So that's very, very important,
and Aeris has delivered
on many of those areas.
So that's it for me.
I'd like turn it over to Drew.
And he can talk to you a
bit about the technical side
of the IoT integration.
DREW JOHNSON: Thank you, Bryan.
And thank you.
We're so proud, and
grateful, actually,
to have Mitsubishi as
a customer of ours.
It's fantastic.
And I'll just say we use
the word automotive grade,
those words, actually, as a
bit of a proxy for reliability,
and security, and complexity.
And we're really happy
that even though this
is a very mature market
relative to many IoT markets,
that our platform, we're winning
among quite a few automakers,
which is actually very
difficult to become
a supplier of automakers.
So that automotive grade
really does mean something.
So if we kind of go through
several of the key challenges
that Bryan mentioned, one
of them is complexity.
And actually, complexity is one
of the key challenges overall
in the Internet of Things.
It's very difficult,
especially for OEMs who are--
as Bryan mentioned,
generally, their business
has been about making hardware,
potentially for 100 years,
like in the automotive space.
And trying to get to
services and software
can be really challenging.
And there's a lot of
complexity in that.
This picture over
here on the right
is just one view of
some of that complexity.
There there's other views that--
different views of how that
complexity takes shape.
And one of the things
that Mitsubishi
did that was pretty smart to
help manage that complexity was
they created what
I kind of think
of as this pyramid
of responsibility.
So they really only
had two main suppliers.
They had Aeris, and they had
their hardware TCU provider.
And then they counted
on those two providers
to deliver everything else.
So if you kind of go
back to Mario's picture,
pretty much everything
else was delivered
by those two providers.
So Aeris, we
delivered the platform
with all of those
remote operations
and the analytics that's
there, the UIs, the mobile UI
and the smart speaker UIs,
the call center, the cloud,
actually, and the connectivity.
We managed all the connectivity,
as Bryan mentioned.
And then along with
the TCU provider,
we actually shared
responsibility
for the firmware.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute.
OK, and then here
on the right, this
is a picture of our stacks.
Very simplified
picture of our stack.
And if we go to,
again, one of the key
challenges that Bryan
mentioned of how
do you actually deliver rapidly,
both for the initial launch,
and then even being able to add
additional services ongoing.
If you think about a car, it's
in the market for 10 years.
So you really don't want to
have those features frozen
for 10 years.
And you have to have
an architecture then
that can support
that agility, not
just in the delivery
of the initial vehicle,
but actually ongoing over
that 10-year lifecycle.
So this architecture is key.
I'll just walk you
through really quickly.
Each one of these
kind of major boxes
here has actually something like
10 to 20 microservices in it.
So I'm not going to
go through all those,
but I will walk you
through generally
how the architecture looks.
So starting down
here, the edge client,
that's actually software
running in the vehicle.
So that's actually where we
collaborated with the TCU maker
to allow us to put that
edge client in the vehicle.
And that is-- if you look
at previous generations
of connected cars, that
is relatively unique.
A lot of the previous
generation connected cars
did not have an edge
client that was really
an extension of
the Cloud platform.
They actually just aligned
on APIs or protocols.
And that actually is one of
the areas that causes problems
with being able to develop
rapidly and actually
extend the services and
platform eventually later on.
So we have the edge client.
We have our
connectivity platform.
So our connectivity
platform, we'll
talk about that
in the next slide.
The device platform
is actually, again,
really key for being able
to abstract the vehicle
from the rest of the services.
So the edge client, the edge
client includes capabilities,
like connection management,
authentication, authorization,
OTA, all of the local
interfaces to actually perform
remote operations.
All of those
capabilities are here,
but it communicates
back and forth
to the device platform
in an abstraction that
allows us to just
make changes here
without having to make changes
in the full device platform,
or even in the service platform.
So very key for this
is actually getting
that abstraction correct.
And we've seen a lot
of platforms, again,
where there's tight coupling,
especially between here
and here, or maybe even
between here and there,
between the service
platform and the edge
client that actually constrains
those eventual developments.
And just a quick note, if
you think about the IoT core,
the IoT core actually is one
of the microservices here
in the device platform that's
part of the communications
infrastructure.
All right, and then from a
connectivity perspective,
Aeris is actually-- we
provide connectivity
for the Internet of Things
in many, many horizontals.
So we have customers in--
or many, many verticals.
We have customers probably in
every single Internet of Things
vertical in the market.
And what we've seen with
many years of experience,
is generally, particularly
large programs,
they fall apart if the
customer really does not
pay attention to connectivity.
If you really go into
the market and you
think cellular connectivity is
more or less similar to Wi-Fi
or wired and you
ignore the complexities
of cellular
connectivity, then you'll
run into problems at scale.
There will be problems.
If you really just
think about it,
if you have problems maybe with
making calls or connections
in a particular
room of your house,
you can always move to another
room or reposition yourself,
but a car can't do that.
A car sitting in your
garage can't do that.
So you need to have a
connectivity management
platform that's really
optimized for handling
the Internet of Things, which
is very different than what
you need for consumers
and consumer handsets.
And then there's other
aspects of cellular that
come into play, like security.
And we'll talk a little bit
about security in a minute.
Being able to
optimize the response
times across the
cellular connectivity,
you think about a remote
operation on your vehicle,
you need to have it happen
quickly rather than--
and actually, you have to
balance the speed and user
experience with the power
management that's going on
in the vehicle as well.
And as Mario mentioned,
as we move from 3G to 4G,
even on into 5G, and potentially
even incorporating Wi-Fi,
you need to have a
connectivity management
system that can actually handle
all of those different modes.
All right, and then one of the
other challenges that Bryan
mentioned was security.
And with regards
to security, you
need to really take a
security domain approach.
There are actually at least
eight major security domains
in the connected vehicle space.
And each one of those
security domains
needs attention independently.
And then you need to make sure
that you cover the full supply
chain.
If you think about it from
the time the car is created
until the time the
car is crushed,
there's so many different
parts of that lifecycle
that come into play.
And each one of those
stages in that lifecycle
needs to be secured.
And then relative to
connectivity, again,
if you ignore connectivity--
something that we
see, again, have
seen from customers
in the past, that
connectivity is a really
critical part of the security
domain.
Again, relative to
cellular, cellular
was designed to be a many to
many type of communication
mechanism if you think about it.
So you have to apply
the security mechanisms
to turn that many to many
into a secure, private network
mechanism.
And one of the most
famous hacks, actually,
in connected vehicle
in the last few years
was at least
exacerbated by the fact
that the connectivity
security domain was ignored.
So there was a--
in that case, there was a hole
in the vehicle on the edge,
which in itself
was bad, but what
happened was the hole was
exposed via connectivity so
that anybody who was on
that connectivity provider
could actually access that hole.
And it's key here actually to
assume that you're never done.
You have to regularly
scan, and that's also
why OTA updates are so critical.
All right, and then
the last thing,
I thought I'd spend a few
slides just talking about why
Aeris is moving to GCP.
And we're really proud,
as Mario mentioned,
to become a partner of Google.
And last year, like
perhaps some of you,
I was sitting here
at Google Next,
and we were contemplating
potentially moving to GCP.
And ultimately, I just want
to share some of the reasons
why we chose to make that move.
So number one, we think of
Cloud 2.0 is really Kubernetes.
If you think about
Cloud 1.0 being really
about virtual
machines primarily,
Cloud 2.0 is about Kubernetes.
And of course, Google is creator
and the biggest contributor
to Kubernetes.
But in particular, GCP
has really a large lead
on managed Kubernetes.
So if you look really
across the cloud providers,
and you do your own
evaluation like we did,
you'll find that in
managed Kubernetes,
Google actually has
a very strong lead.
And the way we look at it is--
and I love our
DevOps team, but if I
have to make a choice of
hiring one more DevOps person
or hiring a data scientist, I'd
rather hire the data scientist.
And getting a good managed
Kubernetes infrastructure
in place allows us to control
really are our DevOps workload.
The second reason is about
really being customer
and developer friendly.
I go back to this
quote at the bottom,
that's my quote actually
of Cloud 1.0 ROIs.
If you think about
those ROIs, those
were really about having your
own private data center where
you had tens of usually,
operations, usually
standard operations folks,
and the ROIs were relatively
easy for kind of reducing a
large number of operations
folks and moving those to be
DevOps folks in the cloud.
But now, your CEO, or when you--
when I say your CEO, I mean my
CEO is actually saying, hey,
we're still spending too
much money in the cloud.
What can we do that's
an improvement?
And again, as we kind of
look around the industry
at different cloud providers,
what we see out of GCP
is that, just from cost
transparency and kind
of optimization [? ease, ?]
there are really
large advantages in GCP.
And I think you can get to
some of these same capabilities
in some of the other
cloud providers,
but not nearly as easily.
And for us, in our kind
of old cloud provider,
we actually ended up
with 15 separate accounts
in order to manage all
of the access controls
and have the cost
visibility that we wanted.
And what we see in GCP is
it's just tremendously easier
to more automatically get
that visibility, the access
control, and the
cost optimizations
that we're trying to get to.
And then the last big reason
is we do see this opportunity
to actually collaborate with
Google and their customers
on making the Internet of
Things less complex and easier
for OEMs.
We really see that nearly
every single OEM on the planet
is on this journey from
unconnected product
to connected service.
And that's really
important, that difference
between those words,
product and service.
As Bryan mentioned, oftentimes
in the automotive space,
the only interaction that the
actual automaker might have
is maybe even just at the
point of the dealership.
And that might be
the last interaction
that they have with the
customer previously.
So the fact that they can
have a connected vehicle,
they can understand how
the consumer and the owner
is actually using
the vehicle, they
can have opportunities
to interact
with the owner on a
regular basis, really,
it's a game-changer
in the business,
and in the business
of many OEMs.
So for us, we see some of the
areas that we're working with,
provisioning at IoT
scale in a secure way,
seamless connectivity and
OTA updates of edge devices.
I've mentioned a
few times about why
that's important in the space.
The advanced remote
operations services.
If you think about, especially
in the moving things
area, the fact that you
have MQTT and IoT core
and some of those
things, those are great.
But it doesn't make sense
for every single OEM
to reinvent how remote
operations are done.
A lot of that needs to be more
standardized and sharable and
leverageable.
And then the automotive
grade edge computing.
If you think about a
future where, again, the--
if you think about Web 1.0
to Web 2.0, in Web 1.0,
you also had more of
very rudimentary kind
of logic getting pushed to
the edge to your browser,
and then kind of interacting
over rudimentary APIs
back to the platform.
That's a similar thing that's
going to happen as in the edge
computing area.
So that we have the
edge computing logic
is more of a adaptable,
updatable set of logic
that can get easily
pushed to the edge
and interact in a
really optimized way
with the cloud-based platform.
So these are some of
the areas that we're
really excited about working
with Google on and being
able to provide to some
of Google's customers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]